[Music]
adding bling to your smile isn't
anything new but one of the busiest ways
to do it these days is with toothed gems
they're small crystals diamonds or
charms that are literally glued to the
enamel of your teeth tooth generation 2
grills popularized by african-american
hip-hop artists in the 80s and 90s
celebrities including Drake Haley Bieber
and Katy Perry
seem to love adding them to their smiles
we visited dr. Bobbie Peterson who
places tooth gems for celebrities like
Justine Skye to see how one is placed by
one of her repeat clients I got my first
tooth gem about six months ago I love
how it blings on this side I'm like
besides so empty that I would love that
when I switch angles to have a little
bling on this side also this procedure
does not damage your teeth in any way
this is why I love to do them dr. Bobby
Peterson always conducts a consultation
to help the client find their ideal gem
and it's placement her gems include
crystals diamonds and precious metals
each one ranges from 50 to $500 subtle
gems are usually placed on the canines
first premolars and visible teeth below
for a more noticeable look tooth gems
are placed on the central and lateral
incisors
now that I'm looking at it I think I
want to add one to the right the
placement process is pretty
straightforward and takes about five
minutes first the tooth is completely
isolated using a retractor and cotton
rolls after it is cleaned and dried an
etchant solution which prepares the
tooth surface for the glue is applied
once the solution is wiped and rinsed
away more air is applied the bonds of
the sealant is placed onto the tooth and
dried with a UV light but glue is
squeezed over the ceilin and the tooth
gem is placed using wax the gem is
adjusted to a precise placement once the
client confirms that they like the gems
position it is cured to the tooth using
a UV light which takes about one minute
the gem is polished and good to go
[Music]
there are no negative long-term effects
of you wearing the stone unless you get
your teeth whitened every month and your
teeth around the gym are 5 shades whiter
it's a little bit harder to bleach the
area that's underneath the stone I love
it I thought I wanted on this size but
after she you know showed me the
placement option I definitely wanted it
you know right next to the one I
originally had I am so excited to show
it off to everybody
I really feel pretty like I feel
gorgeous
[Music]
you